some of the worst fire conditions are in
California at least ten large fires are
burning across the state including those
in Mendocino and Lake counties north of
San Francisco they've burned about
115,000 acres and are only partly
partially contained thousands of
residents have been forced from their
homes
excessive heat is also a threat
thousands of miles away in Europe at the
peak of the tourist season temperature
records that have stood for four decades
are falling it will be 115 degrees in
Cordoba Spain today and a hundred eleven
degrees in Lisbon Portugal today's
readings will be the hottest of the
weekend Seth Doane has more europeans
are united in seeking shade and some ice
water by now many are wishing those
temperature readings were in Fahrenheit
not Celsius Spain and Portugal are
getting the brunt of the hot air that's
blown in from Africa wildfires which are
a regular problem in summer months are
fueled by these hot dry conditions we
witnessed the fire devastation last week
in Greece
it's triple digit temperatures at peak
tourist times Rome's Spanish Steps
were searing so the Lockhart family gave
up their photo-op tried to sit down for
a fresh cross but they were burning our
bosoms so we decided to move down the
city of Rome distributed 8,000 bottles
of water earlier this week to try to
stave off dehydration while the city's
Zoo tried blocks of ice and refreshing
fruit to keep tigers and hippos cool
farmers in Germany are seeking more than
a billion dollars in drought aid there's
the same pain in the UK Simon make ylim
figures the drought already cost him
forty thousand dollars if you became a
regular thing yeah we'd have to just
change the way we farm so what we see
right now is really a warning sign of
what's to come
Justin Warland Time Magazine's climate
reporter blames the unusually hot air on
warming arctic temperatures due to
greenhouse gases human fingerprints are
all over this particular heat wave a
mountain glacier in Sweden melted so
much it's no longer that country's
highest point while down at sea level
folks flocked to the beach or to
ice-cream stance but any relief was
fleeting for CBS this morning Saturday
Seth Doane Rome